>>> THIS MORNING, AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
HE HIS A MESSAGE FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN AHEAD OF HIS SUMMIT
MEETING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
LATER THIS MOVEMENT CNN'S
MATTHEW CHANCE LIVE AGAIN WITH
THIS EXCLUSIVE.
MATTHEW.
>> Reporter: JOHN, THANKS VERY
MUCH.
IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SITUATION.
HE WORKS IN WHAT HE CALLS A
SWEAT SHOP MAKING CLOTHES AND
HE'S NOW LOOKING TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN IN HIS UPCOMING SUMMIT
WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN TO
NEGOTIATE HIS RELEASE.
FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS PAUL
WHELAN HAS LANGUISHED IN RUSSIAN
JAILS INSIFGT HE'S AN INNOCENT
PAWN IN A POLITICAL GAME.
>> I WANT TO TELL THE WORLD I'M
THE VICTIM OF A POLITICAL
KIDNAPPING AND RANSOM.
THE FORMER U.S. MARINE HAS
SPOKEN TO CNN FROM HIS PENAL
COLONY AHEAD OF A MUCH
ANTICIPATED SUMMIT WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND RUSSIAN PRESIDENT.
>> IF YOU CAN GET A MESSAGE TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AHEAD OF THIS
MEETING, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> ACTION IS NEEDED IMMEDIATELY.
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN CANNOT STAND
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS RUSSIA AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY NEED TO ANSWER THIS HOSTAGE
SITUATION AND RESOLVE IT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
I WOULD ASK PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
AGGRESSIVELY DISCUSS THIS WITH
HIS RUSSIAN DOWNTER PARTS.
>> Reporter: IT WAS AT THIS
UPSCALE HOTEL IN MOSCOW IN 2018
WHERE WHELAN WAS DETAINED BY THE
RUSSIAN SECURITY SERVICES, THE
OLD KGB, ACCUSED OF RECEIVING A
FLASH DRIVE CONTAINING
CLASSIFIED SITUATION.
IN A CLOSED TRIAL, HE WAS
SENTENCED TO 16 YEARS AFTER
BEING CONVICTED OF ESPIONAGE, A
TRUMPED UP CHARGE, HE SAID,
INTENDING TO MAKE HIM A VALUABLE
BARGAINING CHIP FOR THE KREMLIN,
SOMETHING RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
DENY.
>> THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE, THERE
WAS NO EVIDENCE.
THE SECRET TRIAL WAS A SHAM.
THIS WAS DONE PURELY FOR
POLITICAL MOTIVE AND IT'S REALLY
UP TO THE GOVERNMENT TO SORT OUT
EITHER AN EXCHANGE OR SOME SORT
OF RESOLUTION.
MY HOPE IS THAT IT WILL BE
QUICK.
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
>> I HAVE NOT HAD A SHOWER IN
TWO WEEKS.
I CANNOT USE A BARBER.
I HAVE TO CUT MY OWN HAIR.
>> Reporter: EVER SINCE HIS
ARREST, THERE'S BEEN A SERIES OF
WELFARE CONCERNS.
THE STATE OF RUSSIA IS POOR.
HE SPENDS HIS DAYS SEWING
CLOTHES IN A PRISON FACTORY, BUT
HEALTH ISSUES DURING THE COVID
PANDEMIC ARE A WORRY.
>> SO TELL ME HOW ARE YOU DOING?
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I'M DOING OKAY.
I'VE GOT SOME SORT OF ILLNESS
RIGHT NOW.
I CALL IT A KENNEL COUGH.
IT KIND OF COMES AND GOES IN THE
BARRACKS.
PEOPLE HAVE IT, GET BETTER, AND
HAVE IT AGAIN.
GETTING MEDICAL CARE IS
DIFFICULT.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
COVID?
I IMAGINE THE VACCINE HASN'T
REACHED YOU.
>> WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT.
I HAD ONE SHOT AND I SHOULD HAVE
A SECOND SHOT IN TWO WEEKS.
>> OH, WOW.
>> SO THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> Reporter: A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION PERHAPS, BUT FOR PAUL
WHELAN, IT MAY STILL BE A LONG
ROAD HOME.
THE RUGS HAVE MADE NO SECRET OF
THE FACT THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
U.S. JAILS WHO WEREN'T RELEASED
INCLUDING SOMEONE WHO WAS
CONVICTED OF SMUGGLING COCAINE
AND ARMS TRAFFICKERS.
THOSE ARE THE GUYS POTENTIALLY
THEY WANT TRADED OUT.
>> HAS THERE BEEN ANY CHANGE IN
THE POSTURE WITH THE SHIFT IN
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE UNITED
STATES?
>> Reporter: WELL, I THINK THAT
BOTH ADMINISTRATIONS, BOTH THIS
ONE AND THE PREVIOUS ONE HAD
BEEN WORKING TO TRY AND SORT OF
FIND A NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT TO
THIS, WORK OUT WAYS IN WHICH
THERE COULD BE A PRISONER SWAP
OR RELEASE OF PAUL WHELAN.
AND ANOTHER IS TREVOR REED ALSO
SERVING A LONG SENTENCE HERE.
BUT WITH THIS BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THERE'S AN
EFFORT UNDER WAY WITH ANTHONY
BLIN KIN WORKING WITH U.S.
OFFICIALS TO TRY TO BRING THIS
MATTER TO A CLOS